right we're
live you welcome everybody and um we'll
we'll start the meeting so just by way
of introduction I'm councelor Jarman I'm
chair of the panel and with me are
councilors Brotherton and Holden and
we're assisted the panel are assisted
today by officers from legal licensing
and governance
governance um now this is a review
applicated for a review of an existing
premises license the Garrick Head mide
Road
flixton and the review has been
triggered by a submission from Elizabeth
Pritchard who's here today believe hello
hi Elizabeth um from Environ from the
environmental health Team uh the Trapper
case will be presented by Mr James Parry
legal representative and assisted by
Joan Bo from from
licensing um now from the the premises
uh the Garrick said on the license
holder which is punch
taverns uh we have um Mr War morning
morning you'll be leading there's a Miss
Edmonds Miss IO and uh Miss slay to the
DPS okay thank you very much and uh and
and
welcome now I believe that we have a
request for uh an adjournment of the
meeting from the applicant
Trafford uh which is being contestant
contested by the
licy so what I propose to do is that we
we hear from Mr Parry the applicant why
he wants to to make the move for an
adjournment then I will ask um Mr War to
respond um of why he opposes the
deferral of journ um and then the panel
will ask questions of each party may ask
questions of each party about the
submission and then each party can ask
questions of each other I will then
adjourn the meeting and we'll take legal
advice and then come uh call call well
we'll ask everybody to leave the room
and then after we've taken advice call
them back to deliver the decision with
reasons um so is everybody clear about
the procedure
yeah
of
CAS so very
care
[Music]
s's okay well that's noted and I can
assist on that that point chair because
I doubt there will be very much between
Mr war and I certainly the usual
position in proceedings such as this if
any questions were to be asked of
somebody uh that was likely to interfere
with a prosecution then they would have
to be told that they are not obliged to
answer that question um because they
have a like right to uh remain silent in
relation to it uh it would also be right
that they shouldn't be reporting on it
um because that would could has the
potential to be prejudicial uh there is
a prosecution that has been brought uh
it is not due to be heard until next
year because of the congestion in the
courts uh and there is little any of us
can do to expedite that at this stage uh
in relation to these proceedings but I
certainly would have no objection to any
part of the hearing should we get to
that stage uh in relation where that
might be discussed being heard in heard
in in private okay thank you Mr P we may
not get that prob let's see um Mr Parry
you you want to read with your
submission please yes um you'll be aware
we we have a bundle of evidence you have
a bundle of evidence that you have
received uh in relation to this matter
from the uh from the uh respondents uh
that was received into the office on I
understand on the 24th of November uh
which was a Friday uh afternoon it was
circulated on the
27th uh I don't base my adjournment on
The Late service of that uh material um
but I do base it on the on the fact that
it is my job on behalf of those I
represent to ensure that you have the
full information before you upon which
you can determine this
application and I received information
yesterday that the history of these
premises and indeed of the designated
premises supervisor that I have been
provided with
uh was not complete and uh I have
received a statement dated the 28th of
November
2023 which was completed by uh Neil
Courtney the council's community safety
officer who has access to GMP
systems uh which details a number of
incidents in relation to the premises
including incidents on the 21st of June
2020 the 4th of July 2020 the 11th of
July
2020 the 7th of November
2020 uh the 18th of February
2022 the 17th of April 2022 the 3rd of
June
2022 the um 2nd of August 2022 the 7th
of August
2022 the 23rd of February
2023 and the 8th of April
2023 in relation to those incidents
three of them uh concerns allegations
which were treated by the police as
being serious
assaults you have not seen that evidence
um but it is evidence as to in the
submission my submission evidence that
would go to how successfully or
otherwise the premises were being
run uh it would
engage um the princip iple as that you
must consider irrespective of what the
review uh has been founded upon as to
the prevention of crime and disorder and
the prevention of public nuisance uh and
it is information that you should you
should see and be aware of I'm aware
that my friend for the uh for for punch
taverns uh and the designated premises
supervisor objects to that evidence
being shown to you uh he will no doubt
say it has been produced later
and ask why well um the reason that this
review uh comes before us today uh is
because it has been brought there is no
time limit under the hearing regulations
or under the act when a review may be
may be sanctioned may be brought um
there is a time limit in relation to
prosecutions but that doesn't apply to
these these proceedings and the review
is therefore brought uh in in accordance
with the statutary uh Provisions uh it
is regrettable that the information that
I was presented with uh last night uh
which I saw for the first time this
morning was not presented to to you it
may be
suggested that um there has been no
Communications with the designated
premises supervisor this year um that
however uh would appear not to be the
case because if you look at page 26 six
of your bundle you will see uh that um
Elizabeth Pritchard uh was uh
communicating with uh one Joshua Barker
and D Slater the designated premises
supervisor in January and April of this
year and uh inviting them to come to an
interview I accept they had every right
uh not to come to that interview but in
so far as it might be suggested that
there were no
Communications there were uh and from
what I have seen there would appear to
have been somewhat
onesided so the application is that you
should be put in possession of the full
evidence in relation to this case uh not
uh the partial evidence that you have at
the moment because that is in the public
interest it is in the public interests
and the inhabitants of this burough and
those that use the Garrick's head that
you should have the full uh set of
information that is available to you to
conduct what is essential in inquiry and
in order to get that to you in a form
where I can present it to you and a
friend can respond to it it seems to me
only the only way forward is for these
proceedings to be adjured
today I understand that if they were to
be ajour today they could be uh
reconvened in January next year so in
the scheme of things we are not looking
at a lengthy delay I should also mention
because I've mentioned it to my friends
that
uh although he may say well you're not
entitled to see this evidence we object
it's late will put us in a rather
bizarre position because in the event
that any party appealed these
proceedings and it went to a hearing in
the magistrates courts the rules there
are that the hearing is Den noo and all
evidence can go before the magistrates
Court
um which is which causes something of an
anachronism to what you might be told in
a moment those are my submission this
stage okay thank you Mr Parry um I mean
I I did have a couple of questions
relating to the police and matters
after this time last year Chris Chris
Christmas last year but they take for
what you've said they may well be dealt
with in the uh the late
submissions um so I I will hold on them
for now we'll take advice on what you
said I'll just ask if any of the the
panel have any questions from Mr
Parry no okay in that case I'll ask Mr
War to to
respond
please um
happy happy to use it if that helped um
look
start with this fairly py observation
but I think it's um obvious why it's
important I've been doing this for 20
years I've been involved in the
licensing act hearings since 2005 and
never have I had a situation
where I've had a heard a submission like
that in terms of the good reasons why
you should accept late evidence never um
or indeed adjourn for the evidence
that's purported to be relevant to this
case and let me explain why I'm very
pleased to hear that Mr Parry accepts
evidence was served in good time and in
time time with the regulations the
regulations are very clear that evidence
has to be served um it it cannot be
served at a hearing without the consent
of all parties and you won't be
surprised to hear that we don't consent
to the evidence that seems to be brought
before us today uh to being included um
you've heard a list of what's in there
most of it seems to be relevant to 2020
and 2022 um and an incident in February
and an incident in April 2023 so there's
not much meat to the bones to to to
what's being said
anyway the police have served a
representation the police have also
served anciliary documents so you've got
the police's case here from what I
understand from what Mr Perry was saying
this statement he refers to isn't even
from a police officer it's from someone
else who's gone through police records
now you have the police evidence before
you it's very clear and a supplemental
statement that can all be drawn out as
part of the evidence of this matter so
there's no need to adjourn for those
reasons and if we have a quick look at
the Timeline here it's quite
Illuminating the we're dealing with two
test purchases okay that's the sum total
of the evidence before you bu the
applicant the second one happened in
December 2022
that's 11 months
ago um we have service of a a
prosecution eight months later in August
which has to go through a whole process
of Investigations so there's been a lot
of time to do investigations before that
so from December until October the
service of these review papers we have
nine
months now page seven of the papers make
it very clear the only licens objective
being engaged here is the protection of
children from harm no other licensing
objectives are engaged so when Mr Perry
starts talking about public nuisance and
crime and disorder he simply can't even
raise
them they're not in his papers and the
hearings regulations are very clear
about you can only expand upon that
which is in your application or
representation we've had two months from
service of the review to get to here
today the police served their evidence
on the 26th of October so at that time
it was clear to the applicant what the
police were saying and then he served
further papers uh on the 22nd of
November so there still been enough time
to actually give everyone pre-warning
that this was coming not to spring it on
us at a
hearing
um the police at
um in their supplemental documents make
it clear no further crime reports linked
to the premises since August 2022 now
that's evidence that the police are
satisfying that they've done their tests
and their trolls so I'm not prepared to
accept the word of someone we don't know
about over the police officer whose job
it is to be here representing the
police's position
today so Mr Parry client has had
significant time to
investigate um and and frankly trying to
throw mud at this last moment just
seems I just find it very difficult to
understand why we have to question the
relevance of it in any event the review
is simply not bought on crime and
disorder uh or nuisance
grounds um and given the amount of time
since the test purchases there is no
excuse and it's not in the public
interest to delay now there's 80 pages
that were submitted in support of their
review so it's not like they've been
scrabbling to get papers together
they've had a really good go at this
with their review
bundle so why are we getting this all
very late in the
day I I also have to comment I've not
had any response on the condition I
conditions that we propos that you've
seen in our paper despite trying to get
some kind of response back uh since the
9th of November in fact in fness I got a
response very late in the day yesterday
just saying we're not going to engage on
that effectively the deadlines for
hearing these things are set to ensure
that matters are dealt with fairly and
expeditiously there's a significant
number of parties that weren't engaged
with prior to this application for
German who've made representations there
are a significant number of parties who
are affected by the stress of these
matters being
delayed there's been a significant
amount of work by your officers here
committee officers you coming today us
coming today I had to come up two
o'clock yesterday afternoon stay in a
hotel Dawn's obviously had to make
arrangements to have someone look after
the pub two people from punch have come
here today they've had to crash their
calendars for the whole day it's not
insignificant that that has been done so
is it in the public interest to delay
for what appears to be a number of
incidents that are historical nothing to
do with um prevention of uh children
from harm crime um sorry the protection
of children from crime licensing
objective that would allow us to say
that it's reasonable a to even admit
these papers or be to adjourn the matter
my um submission is no we should go
ahead today we should go ahead on the
reams of evidence we have before us but
we've all taken time to come here and if
there's anything that needs to be
discussed in terms of an appeal I don't
like any party threatening an appeal
it's true that an appeal's denovo but
frankly this hearing is denovo based on
two events that happened in
2022 that's for them to raise it the
appeal that's nothing to do with this
committee or any it should have any
bearing on your determination today
we've all actively engaged in the
process and ultimately this
application's been delayed long enough I
I submit we should hear it today they
have a lot of time to prepare I can't
see that any of the evidence that they
reporting book before you would make any
difference sorry those are my submission
I'm sorry I'm a bit head up about it but
it's very last minute and it just
frankly it's
frustrating
question I don't have questions but I
will refer to the regulations because
they have been mentioned and it's
appropriate to deal with them the two
relevant regulations would appear to be
regulation 18 which says this in
considering any representation or notice
made by a party The Authority may take
into account documentary or other
information produced by a party in
support of their application
representations or notice as applicable
either before the hearing or with the
consent of the other parties at the
hearing uh of course uh if these matters
were to be adjourned
then um it would be and the reason I
seek an enurement is to enable that
evidence to be provided to the other
party before uh the adjourned hearing so
that objection would fall away uh the
second relevant
uh regulation is regulation 19 which
says the authority shall disregard any
information given by a party or to any
person to whom permission to appear at
the hearing is given by The Authority
which is not relevant to a
their application representations or
notice is applicable or in the case of
another person the application
representations or notice uh of of the
party requesting their appearance and B
the promotion of the licensing rep uh
objectives or in relation to a hearing
to consider a notice given by the chief
officer place on the crime prevention uh
objective well I again we say that the
evidence that we have is relevant to the
representation that you have been made
but it also encompasses the other uh
licensing objectives in relation to that
one other point Mr one made um he didn't
want us to consider information from a
person who isn't present at the
proceedings Mr Courtney is present at
the proceedings he is the author of the
statement and would be in a position to
give evidence about it should that be
necessary and I am in a position to call
him should that be
required should not present today he he
is here today he could be called if
required if if
required I me I I think it's just this
simple observation that if we could all
delay hearings in our interests at the
last minute by chucking a load of extra
papers at the committee we've all been a
pretty bad way dealing with licensing
matters i' I've heard nothing from Mr
Parry that gives me any confidence that
that having any other Witnesses here
about some papers that are mainly
historical when you have the police
officers here who can answer questions
about the police matters are in any way
relevant or in the public interest for
delaying this further we've been delayed
enough
[Music]
the